inside news it appears that Kojima
Productions may have indeed disbanded
that's according to arctica Akio the
Japanese voice actor / snake in Metal
Gear Solid archaea revealed the news in
a Twitter update which reads Kojima
Productions was forced to disband but it
appears that the work the team has been
putting their utmost effort into is
nearly complete adding I'm not
exaggerating when I say that I expect
metal gear solid 5 the fans and pain
will become their greatest masterpiece
Kaname has not officially announced
whether Kojima Productions has or will
cease to operate this is the latest
entry in the kajima saga which began in
March with the news that consumer
production staff had been given
restricted access to company emails
phone calls and corporate Internet the
staff were made contractors instead of
permanent employees and kajima
production logos were removed from
phantom pain promotional material a
source also claimed that the studio
would likely be disbanded alongside
tajima's departure once metal gear solid
5 development came to a close gamespot
has contacted Konami for a statement
we'll keep you updated as this one
unravels but be sure to let me know what
you think of the situation down in the
comments and for more news be sure to
stay tuned against but